so you want to learn to program probably
the number one question people ask me is
hey I want to learn a program how do I
get started what language should I
choose what languages did you start with
and what books did you read and all this
kind of stuff and my story as far as how
I got started programming is different
writing and just like everybody's story
and reason to want to learn a program is
different and for at least my example
why I wanted to learn a program was
during college I had a lot of little
businesses and investments and stuff and
so if one of my investments was paying
out I would start investing into another
little business and stuff like that so I
was just always doing a lot of little
businesses I had a lot of ideas and just
like any idea it's no good unless you
execute it and try it and practice and
decide what's around it's good and so
either you've got to execute them or
you've got to have someone that's paid
to execute them and in my case I had a
developer and so he did most of the
development for me and then towards the
end of my university career I had the
idea since I was investing in the stock
market I realized how much of an effect
that the news was having on the short
term stock prospects and I just kind of
got the idea well oh I wonder if if you
made a program read text if you could
kind of predict these short-term
movements or find short-term
inconsistencies with the long term
sentiment or overall feeling for that
company and my developer couldn't do
that I couldn't do that and I didn't
have that much money to get a developer
who could do that so then that's kind of
how I set out and decided hey I want to
learn a program is it not only that I
take on the idea of hey a learner
program I took on the probably one of
the most challenging tasks you can even
do it
I mean that's natural language
processing and and machine learning
which is built in to that kind of filled
with natural language processing but
that's what I really wanted to do you
know that was my goal I didn't care
about really anything else but natural
language processing so depending on what
you're interested in that's really where
you start and a lot of languages are
just better documented like in my case
with natural language processing I found
the NL TK there's like this PDF 400 page
text book that you can get and it just
happens that the NL TK module with
Python or NLT K module uses Python and
so that was how I started with Python
and since then I've kind of brand shot I
don't even use an LT K anymore
boy I stuck with Python just because I
learned with Python and it turns out
that pythons actually really it's great
just for rapid development of stuff
performance isn't the best but again
people would Python in any language it's
like you know most languages are really
good for one test but most languages can
do any task right it just kind of
depends on what you're comfortable with
and so just like really anything
anything big you know when someone says
hey you know I want to learn a program
that's a lot like saying hey I want to
learn math right it's a very big field
right and so so if you if you decide
that you know you want to be a
professional programmer you're kind of
setting yourself up for failure right
out of the gate if you decide that your
only goal is to just be a programmer
right well that's really hard to just
kind of encompass everything like you
know I've been programming a lot I've
logged thousands of hours programming
but I'm nowhere near having even like a
10% knowledge of the Python programming
language alone all right
so you know you the best thing you can
do is if you take if you think about
like some of the most challenging
accomplishments you can even have in
life so like one of the probably the
most challenging accomplishments I can
think of is something like becoming like
a Navy SEAL wreck a what they're taught
to do through that and that is it's
obviously very physical
it's also a mental challenge and I would
argue that it's actually more mental
than physical I mean almost anybody can
overcome the physical aspect of doing
Navy SEAL training the mental aspect is
very difficult to get through and I
could be totally wrong I'm not a Navy
SEAL so I'm just speaking out of what
I've read but what they're taught to do
is to take you know the process step by
step and sometimes literally step by
step or write get through it you know
use that stuff can I take one more step
yes or no and usually it's like well I
probably can eke out one more step and
you just can eke out one more step and
then finally you know the months go by
and boom you're Navy SEAL or months ago
or months and years go by and suddenly
you realize that you're actually really
as a skilled programmer now and so with
anything in programming if you really
break it down as far as learning
programming it's just baby steps every
step of the way you never have to make
this like giant leap and also if you
ever look at someone's program once
you've learned the basics of programming
you should find that almost every
program is broken down into pretty short
functions you know maybe 30 40 50 line
functions max and within those functions
you've got variables usually some sort
of a loop like a for loop or a while
loop maybe maybe there's an array and
that's about it I mean they've got the
variables the arrays maybe a simple
simple math and that's it that's all
programming is just a combination of
extremely simple tools and just knowing
how to combine them and what can work
with the other things that's all
programming really is and so the
different fields of programming you're
just kind of learning how to apply these
really basic tools into what you want to
do and a lot of times the hardest part
is just making use of someone else's
like Python we've got modules and a lot
of the learning process isn't learning
programming it's learning how to make
use of someone's module so someone
else's code that's already been written
so you don't have to write thousands of
lines of code so a lot of your learning
is going to be learning some one else's
module and so like that really
and that you just look at the code you
can figure out you just just take big
steps but as far as you know how do you
get started what books can I recommend I
mean I read that NLT kay PDF textbook
and that started me off with Python but
that was because you know I'm not going
to recommend hey here's this natural
language processing textbook this is how
I learned this is how you must learn you
know I learned that because that's what
I was interested in that's what I wanted
to do so my question to everybody when
they asked you know how do I get started
programming I usually respond the
question what do you want to do and what
you should do at that point when you
figure out what it is you want to do
with programming find some some
tutorials by somebody that you really
like or find a book that you enjoy
reading that book about that programming
language and like if you want to do web
development I wouldn't suggest you start
with Python for web development right
you can you can make websites with
Python and Django or flask or gerak or
some of these other web frameworks but I
want to suggest Python is the number one
language for doing that right if you
just want to learn web design oh it's a
PHP it's very basic and simple and
anyone so obviously need to learn HTML
and CSS and all that stuff but it just
depends on what you really want to do if
you want to do data processing I would
say Python you want to do big data
processing I would say Python and
prepare yourself for going into C it's
up like that but it just depends on on
what you want to do and figure that out
I know what your goal is and just take
baby steps towards that goal so anyway
that's my video on how to learn to
program so not to be confused with how
to program there's no code here this is
just how to learn a program just take
baby steps guys just take it one step at
a time and you know you want to have a
goal you want to know what you're
working for
and towards but at the same time don't
just think like you know if you if you
try to think that you're going to become
a professional programmer instantly or
your goal is to become a professional
programmer but that's the only step you
move along the way to your goal you're
going to have a problem so that's a very
daunting task to achieve and you won't
feel any sense of accomplishment and
that was my biggest issue
whenever I knew what I wanted to do I
was doing these Java tutorials or C
tutorials and I wasn't feeling like I
was making any progress towards actually
like reading and understanding texts
with the program and so I didn't get
anywhere with those but when I found
this out on TK book I was like boom this
is exactly the stuff I want to hear
about this is exactly what I want to
know how to work with and it was easy
you know and that's that's what made it
easy for me but that ML TK book is not
going to be easy for someone who doesn't
care about language processing so find
what you want find tutorials and
documentation or written around that
take note of what you want to learn like
what you actually see yourself doing if
it's web development then looking into
stuff like JavaScript and PHP and then
eventually you could branch out and then
Python I think Python is a better back
in there
hello I guess it's really front-end but
it's better for processing that PHP is
or even the Ruby is another good
language it just depends you know and
just try to amount see what you think
and just try to find stuff that's more
geared towards what you want and don't
really worry about what what everyone
else did to learn a program because
you're your own special snowflake I
think that you you're going to learn
your own way and you know what's best
for you as far as learning I mean you
definitely want to ask people about
advice and help I mean there's nothing
wrong with that
but at the same time you don't have to
like mimic what other people actually
did and probably the number one thing
you want to look at look out for at
least that I've found as well as like
when you have a question and you don't
know how to do something maybe and you
ask the way that you ask and you want it
you want to learn how to do something
the easiest way possible right so you
want to learn it in the content like in
the context that you understand
programming and so a lot of times I'll
see people ask questions or even I've
done it myself like I think whenever I
was first starting out I wanted know how
to split up some text by paragraph and I
was thinking I wanted to split it up by
chunks of text and I wanted to somehow
identify a chunk of text and that's how
I was going to split up a paragraph I'm
like asking about this and then I was
asking one of my friends how to you know
how to how did have you identify a chunk
of text based on maybe like the volume
of text all this so why do you want to
do this was I was sort of identify
paragraphs he like
split by newline perfect it's just one
of those things that are sometimes you
have to think about programming like a
backwards way it might be thinking that
you want to do the program linearly but
sometimes it's easier to be like okay
well what's the result that I want and
then work back from that how you might
achieve that result and also just take
note that sometimes it can post a
question on Stack Overflow or something
like this you might be asking your your
result you would always want to say look
what do you actually want to achieve and
at least think about this yourself but
sometimes you'll be asking the wrong
question but other than that as far as
how to learn to program find what you
want take baby steps and that's it
pretty soon you'll wake up and you'll
know a lot about some programming
language and you'll be doing pretty
awesome stuff so anyway hopefully this
video is helpful for some of you guys I
get this question a lot it's kind of a
hard question to answer
so hopefully this helpful answer for you
guys as always thanks for watching